[Music]
today is Cyber Monday and it's predicted
to be the largest online shopping day in
US history like this music we should get
excited shoppers are expected to spend
in seven point eight billion dollars
so-called experience items like cruises
and hotels are expected to be popular
buys last year more than a third of
online sales were made on smartphones
and a Werner is at an Amazon Fulfillment
Center in Robbinsville New Jersey and a
good morning good morning and this
fulfillment center is about the size of
28 football fields if you can imagine it
last year on Cyber Monday
Amazon tells us customers ordered more
than 83 million items worldwide this
year they're expecting them to order
even more
shoppers who avoided freezing
temperatures and long lines on Black
Friday can still search for deals today
Cyber Monday shoppers are expected to
spend about 17 point 6 percent more than
last year but hackers could make
shopping on a budget costly Chris Krebs
the director of the cyber security and
infrastructure Security Agency is urging
shoppers to beware of fake websites and
emails if the deal is sounds a little
too good to be true it probably is
crap says you can protect your personal
information by shopping on a secure
internet connection to avoid being
hacked and pay with a credit card that
offers fraud protection cyber criminals
know that it's you know fertile hunting
ground they know that there are people
out there looking for deals despite the
risks cyber monday sales continue to
jump and retailers are expanding their
promotions putting on week-long cyber
events on Thanksgiving people spent a
record three point seven billion dollars
online this holiday season's online
shopping sales are expected to reach 120
billion dollars it's just a fraction of
overall holiday spending
I do think stores are still the place
that most folks want to go USA Today
national business correspondent Charisse
Jones believes it will take a long time
for Cyber Monday to claim Black Friday's
title as the largest shopping day of the
year
I think that retail the brick-and-mortar
stores really offer this kind of
tangible experience and a lot of younger
shoppers ironically are the ones that
really like that now Amazon tells us
last year on Cyber Monday it sold some
one items per second that means during
the time it took to tell this story John
Amazon probably sold about 90,000
items Wow I think some of those I think
I see my address it was a surprise job
yeah run this surprise but the children
react yeah it doesn't